hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within -
good morning everybody hello hi hello
all around the world we're going right
into I just move my light calm down
there buddy it's too early in the
morning for this alright so uh if where
we last left off we went in the city
hall and we met a guy that unfortunately
there was absolutely nothing we could do
to save them they were already dying and
there's nothing that we could do ah yes
I've been reading chat like before I got
started to news nothing but I'm ready
for soup oh please give me soup Oh
precious soup delivery specialist I
don't think you want my soup geyser I'm
pretty sure even the the monsters in
here don't want my soup so oh let me let
me make sure there's no like goodies in
there oh goody in here is that a Foose
a-ok
oh yeah and I also need to use the
workbench no there's nothing in there I
can use so let me go get that and then
I'm gonna craft up some goodies with
which to surprise the cameraman with uh
I could make some sniper rifle cartridge
I don't think I'm gonna need it in here
because there's just not enough space to
be able to use it
I I can make a poon bolt and then I can
make some handgun bullets and then I
should be good to go so yeah sorry no
colourful shirt today I just I just
happen to pull a a halfway presentable
shirt I'm sorry for the crushing
disappointment that you all are
receiving right now alright how about a
shock bolt because those are always
useful another one and that should be
good for now I can make one sniper rifle
cartridge but I don't want to just
because I don't want to and I'm a boring
person who I can get the critical I can
get the critical hit I forgot about that
yes know this yeah I love my handgun yes
let's go with that one I said oh do I
have to oh there we go
huh every time I come back here I have
no idea what I'm doing
alright blam might as well get some more
firepower that one yes okay so if I need
more crafting parts I can always go back
into the brain area and play more of
those minigames which I probably will do
at some point today
right now it's time to deliver some soup
that pesky anybody anybody here nice
camera set up he's gonna kill me
looks like a lethal I hate the doors in
this game the goddamn squeaks Quan key
doors snake mode engaged
hello you all right there buddy whoo I
don't like it that crap is this
no no no no okay all right just a little
bit though I'm just gonna go into this a
little bit then I'm gonna walk out oh
you know this is a bad idea was that the
front
that's his MO he's somewhere in here
today somewhere in here I saw him walk
in the building I pretty much knew that
from the get-go
good job detective Castellanos you're
really on the case here but that doesn't
mean that I'm safe just because I know
I'm here doesn't mean that I can't be
caught in his trap
yeah what I'm confused by is why he
hasn't put me in the box and killed me
dead because there's been there's been
tons of opportunities where he's taken
my picture and kind of cornered me
unless he just really likes playing with
his prey before he gets them freaking
[ __ ] but that doesn't matter we got
to keep going
anybody in here Lebowski hmm okay yep
see another carer could have gotten me
right then and there but didn't excuse
you
okay see another camera in there that
looks like more like a museum exhibit
but why oh yeah no no I wanted to do
that but I did it the poor precious DSLR
in there that for some reason is on
display if there's supposed to be City
Hall City Hall seems a little weird and
also I got to go back I forgot that
there was another room in there where I
saw a bag of supplies I want to go down
there so yes yes I'm I'm playing the
evil within - yes that is the name of
this game yeah oh okay so in here I know
I saw something right there here we go
give it's a whole duffle bag it's
supposed to be the full bag and not this
[ __ ] okay anyways this a front door
is this where I could have gone in I
suppose a yacht no it's locked
so I did have to go around the back no
matter what I did all right well that
was boring and then I did that so there
we go but why though maybe because I
snuck in there's another opportunity why
isn't he here was he doing what's he
planning
okay back into this I thought there was
gonna be more there boom
shut up you shut up Larry stop falling I
got stuff to do yeah we're gonna be
doing a lot of filming today so I'm
really looking forward to that if if you
guys were looking forward to some cool
stuff that we got in store not just the
van vlogs we actually got some other
stuff that we're filming today that I
think you guys are gonna like we're
gonna try to get four videos done today
I don't even know if we're gonna be able
to do that but we're aiming for four
videos done today this whole week has
been like preparatory work we've been
we've been getting things underway so
that we could have everything in store
and this whole weekend is there's gonna
be a blast of filming and I've got we've
got like four videos today and then I'm
gonna be doing like three or four live
action videos tomorrow and then
hopefully the next day there's a trap
not too tired what's this about oh I
don't know it could be a trap where
you're gonna die Sebastian don't like
this at all oh yeah yeah I also posted
on Facebook this little quote-unquote
pet project that I've been working on
called chicas world it's just a little
something that if you guys are
interested you could check it out why is
their face scratched out nothing to say
about that Sebastian you had you
investigated nothing to say
Oh though these flowers are beautiful
something seems off about them you have
a feeling that you should be extra
careful around the thorns okay let me
just stuff that in my sack I'll put it
in with all my bullets that I got to
reach in to randomly to pull out oh boy
Oh
this expensive looking necklace features
a large gemstone oh I think I know what
I got to do I got a recreate the scene
this camera so old must mean something
yeah must mean something huh do I got
find her arms - all right well there we
are
rotate dock okay looks good to me a
boost
oh why oh don't do that
oh no adjust the focus okay
oh god I hate this all right here we go
[Music]
the head moved so much okay all right
we're gonna carry on you don't move you
don't move you move I swear I'm gonna
shoot you so hard did you move all right
that lamps sure got funky I don't know
why all right investigate it's ticking
the pendulum stopped huh weird about
that almost as if time doesn't mean the
same thing in this place have you been
paying attention to the clocks that's
probably important maybe I don't know
womp okay all right
all right okay all right okay all right
okay we're just gonna pretend like
that's a thing comes up with this stuff
um I think you know the answer to that
Sebastian use your detective skills and
figure out what you're gonna be doing
here oh okay oh oh it's horrible
horrible horrible horrible take this
it's a file decapitated body of girl
found according to KCPD the body of a
woman was found in Chrisman's in park
this morning the victim has been
identified as Emily Lewis an aspiring
model and actress her head has yet to be
recovered but examination of personal
effects found at the scene led to the
identification this is the latest in a
string of unsolved homicides of similar
nature Lieutenant James Van Kirk of the
KCPD homicide division held a press
conference where he confirmed our worst
suspicions that crimson city may be
hunting the hunting ground for a serial
killer
come on scroll scroll never yo Emily's
longtime friend and photographer Stefano
Valentini appeared heartbroken at the
news it's a terrible thing that happened
to my lovely model at least I was able
to capture her essence forever before it
was destroyed me think Stefano who good
old Stefano over here
damn I maybe maybe had something to do
with uh something to do with the
disappearance here still a cold case
still a cold Oh God Oh what are we
looking at and why am I still looking at
it glory Valentini Stefano Stefan tini
Gwen Stefani come on down a pup pup Oh
appreciate I thought those up
poppy she ate the art appreciate the art
no it's appreciate as long as it gets me
closer to you I'll play your game I did
appreciate the art the art was yeah it
was um terrible awful it was
legitimately awful I hated every second
of it it was the worst thing I've ever
seen
Valentini Stefan oh alright well I've
gone as far as I can I've looked at all
the art that I think I've Hey
okay afterglow
oh yes Stephano really took a turn these
days playing with me playing with
Sebastian Castellanos oh that door is
thumpy hmm I wonder what do you guys
think should I walk to her to the
horrible stumping door I'm watching you
door that's your friend over there I
know you can't be up to to much good it
looks like that door is in need of some
soup shut up
did that work alright okay ah okay the
thumping was you splattering it with
blood always a good sign I'm taking this
all plays at a snail's pace I'm a brave
boy but I doll a picture of a door tom
tells me that's it is by me
hahahaha you dick you
[Music]
[Music]
no Stefano mister Valentini that mr.
Valentini the weenie why uh why you do
that okay all right then
well weird a little bit stiff a stiff I
know oh just cuz it's gonna give you
fair warning about how much I hate you
which is a lot so don't do that oh boy
Oh Oh for those of you don't know oh god
I hate mannequins like it's something
about it it's just one of those phobias
where when you look at it your skin just
crawls and hate him okay I'm just gonna
have permanently my gun drawn my soup
deliver oh boy what did I get this is it
a special surprise ah the Mobius agent
in the lobby of City Hall turned into
another frozen display poor son of a
[ __ ] if he wasn't dead before he got
thrown off there he will be if he ever
lambs nothing never on the back of these
sons [ __ ] oh my god
alrighty then another one was he after
Oh what is that
oh no we're Transco or not your heads go
Oh
Sebastian's on the case oh boy I'm not
feeling too comfy about this one guys Oh
golly gosh oh oh you okay all right here
we go uh okay all right yeah
Sebastian ear
okay looking for a Stefano who's there
oh just you can I go over here first sir
I'm gonna inspect what's go oh that was
weird
did you guys see that is there some way
to make this room bigger
wait wait wait what No I'm going crazy
no I'm going crazy all right I'm going
crazy
can I shoot you what happens if I just
oh I should have crafted the sniper
rifle huh
damn it water garden you right there and
your stupid face just blam oh well how
about a bottle can I throw a bottle at
you the oh it's oh it's blocked off see
wait a minute wait a honky honky here ah
oh oh no no no no no no no no no don't
be
[ __ ] please I like you to not be
[ __ ] just one time in your goddamn
life no time in your [ __ ] life just
don't be a douche oh the house don't
look so good now most ofon Oh mr.
Valentini mr. Valentini with the weenie
oh I'm going down okay didn't realize
that was the thing that was happening
all right
well la la la going down the stairs la
la la losing all my hairs la la la oh
source of forever knocked in here okay
yeah yeah I realize this whole episode
I've had this permanent face stuck on my
face just happening so I'm gonna go
other approaches now with a nice
heartwarming smile I hate this
everything is horrible
ah life is a misery in this place why
couldn't I kick that door open
do you want some soup sue fixes all your
problems huh oh my leg oh my light
barely I can't draw my gun okay okay
well time to approach this problem with
a smile smile solve everything
oh look it's those things and I had oh
no oh no not me not me anything no
that's a big thing Hey Oh what are these
things
Oh
No
uh oh no oh no it's horrible
Oh God oh it's the worst thing I've ever
seen
oh boy yeah
they shouldn't have put a serial killer
in this place because I think that's
what happened a serial killer was
brought into Union and is depraved mind
kind of broke everything which is
wonderful oh boy
okay how do I get out of here do I get
out of here oh boy here we go
all right scrawled messily on some kind
of fancy card - beautiful - leaving the
street
I had to display them wish that I could
take credit but it's nice to know that
there are other artists in here with me
what too beautiful to leave in the
street oh no there are there are another
artists I'm pretty sure this is just the
result of Oh God
I'm pretty sure this is just the result
oh oh oh oh I thought the bubbles on
your skin were moving I think they might
be yep they are they are they're very
clearly moving yeah they're moving uh
blah
can I melee you oh god I didn't expect
that to actually do anything oh I'm so
sorry about that oh I am so sorry
I'm gonna smash up your art ah God
horrible why am I doing this why I don't
know I just feel like maybe I'm putting
them out of their misery
this doesn't seem to be helping I'm
sorry but maybe I'm not sorry if it's
all fake
Oh baby its misery in perpetuity maybe
they're already dead I don't know Oh God
boy God yeah if they're alive what if
these people are alive and they're just
trapped that's kind of like my only
reasoning into doing this okay all right
okay
I helped what I could I'm out of here
now Oh Sebastian did his part Oh God
hookie sebastio dear detective
Castellanos on the job detective
Castellanos on the Yabba
oh hello sorry is that water or tears or
what is that why is that there
why is it glowing red on that one corner
I saw that oh boy here we go
hello mo you garan me up for something
name let you might be Goering me up for
something ah ah a full clip of bullets
you say oh I can't go back there oh okay
hello
this has to be the emitter the emitter
all that well what am I looking at I
hear it I don't see it oh oh where you
at I hear you where you at whoa okay
your footsteps don't seem to be
following any sort of logic so I'm gonna
assume that this oh this ain't gonna
work you know what I'm gonna scout
around the room before I go to the big
thing in the middle because that seems
like a trap yeah oh yeah oh you guys
know what's going on it's soup time baby
hope I can sneak snug yeah probably not
though Oh okey-dokey then
alright doesn't seem to be anything over
here
my sneaking skills don't seem to be
helping much when I'm gonna keep trying
damn it I'm fooling that okay let me get
up to full health actually then I'm
gonna grab that okay let's do this thing
whatever you're gonna do do to me now
I've got one of those I have one I put
it in my bag with the roses that are
deadly yeah go for it Oh 90 seconds
oh that doesn't look good that looks
awful
oh boy okay all right then ah hello no
turn around Sebastian
Oh ooh nice draw you almost got him oh
that it is searching for me for so long
Stefan although I have come so far oh
but wait it's not me you seek is it no
it's the girl I should be offended but
how can I be you're not the only person
who wants her power for getting dark
higher up in here there is another one
far more deserving one who can offer
rewards you could never imagine so sorry
but you've been outbid no oh
Oh beautiful
but not yet finish i am stefano oh wow
now you are my arm Valentini [ __ ] bang
blam boom boom boom oh ha ha ha ha I'll
pass I'll pass pass pass I don't need no
I don't
oh the emitter from activating Oh
stim stompy ain't you obscuri oh we're
just em stomp off - oh no where am I
so what do I do oh okay alright
[Applause]
don't like that those bad idea oh that
was a bad idea
Oh hate you I hate you I hate you
oh I hate you and your ballet tiptoes
okay so I think I just got to try to get
to the admit er itself cuz I don't think
I can deliver soup to that thing I don't
see a mouth which which to intake soup
so oh stop moaning stop moaning good
thing I'm full of spooky skills Oh yo yo
what if I just go in here
okay well that didn't work good thing
I'm smoking stop moaning right how do I
shoot the camera okay I'll try to shoot
the camera this time
are you gonna go
[Music]
literally the worst thing oh I didn't
see me okay see if I can get a shot on
the lens where you bought it god damn it
you moving so fast what oh god oh god I
tried I tried god it's such hide it
didn't work didn't take didn't develop
oh there we go I just have to hold it
off okay well I wasted a lot of bullets
for that hey I'm right here oh that's
not good that's not good I'm right here
I'm right here come get me
oh yeah no no no no how about you don't
okay right in the bulb I gotta shoot it
in the bulbar Oh God uh you're ruining
all the bulbs god aah oh yeah yeah yeah
okay so it's not okay
sneaky time Diggy you never knew oh god
damn it stop that I've got a shotgun
no this is not a shotgun this is a
shotgun there we go
shotgun seems to be affected because
that Lee uh yeah okay okay all right
are you gonna go I'm so sneaky I'm so
sneaks knocking ho
come on all right whoops wall that's a
problem
where'd you go just hop moaning that is
literally the worst come at me come at
me why that's the opposite of good
oh uh I could need to take some belt Oh
didn't work it oh why are you on the
ceiling all right come on come on Oh
dad's office okay
just don't do that there you go on the
ground come here come at me come on
there we go
hey ye a ye oh that's not good
come on come on give me the time give me
the time come on oh yeah oh oh you lose
oh I wouldn't you lose are you dead now
for some reason well that ain't good
yes all right even oh my eyes my eyes
all right well that's good save my own
ass but what am I supposed to do now
yeah gone he didn't leave Lily here
where did he take her oh this is hard to
look at it about this huh kid bed [ __ ]
maybe I'll get a signal outside maybe or
maybe not oh geez
do I have a map no no map data victory
for me but not my preferred delivery
method of swoop where these always open
I have no idea who these side rooms here
before I can't remember
oh well that works out well but that guy
that why did that guy leave me in here
with that thing to face the obscura with
the risk of me stabilizing everything
because I'm pretty sure that he can't
execute all of his plans if I've
stabilized things mm-hmm
there we go that's a hefty hefty sack no
know what word I was going for there but
that's a hefty happy sack of supplies oh
all right oh this is where the guy fell
fell this fell this is where the guy was
thrown off and probably shot stabbed and
or decapitated one of or all of the
above I'm not sure which one it might
have been but it might have been all of
those okay so where the hell are we
going now I I'm doing wonderfully today
today is gonna be a very very productive
day like I said before we've got tons of
stuff that we're gonna be filming today
and all weekend long so in order to
maintain a conflict-free and obz Obi's
--nt population we must provide
bureaucratic systems and increase the
illusion and productivity to that end a
City Hall will be rendered to represent
a seat of government each citizen will
be required to submit for a series of
licenses that will require several forms
and accompanying fees content to be
determined fabrication teeth just there
making up forms and fees and
licenses for them to feel like they're
in normal society a mayoral election
will be held in which citizens will be
able to vote between two operatives of
our choice
following standard real-world election
processes already in place new Union and
expansion renders will retain the
America on a build mold but retrograded
by 30% to allow for citizen domicile
improvement and individualization these
new measures should keep the populace
calm and normalized the docile populace
will aid in the expansion of Union which
will ultimately lead to enough citizen
memory units to achieve phase two but oh
why though why like why though that's
the biggest question that I can't get
through my head but why though why would
you do this all of this what's the
purpose to what end are you doing it I
should've done that I would have just
gotten coffee damn it I'm an idiot I was
too panicked about my own conundrums huh
anyway let's get back downstairs and
find the guy who's dead maybe they
didn't know but maybe they didn't though
yeah maybe it is maybe maybe you don't
understand the whole truth of it maybe
you're being lied to from the get-go but
the lie isn't any better than the truth
you know what I mean
it's a vice Jane it's an ice giant the
basin do you understand them you guys
hear that okay I'm just going back to
the safe room real quick good news Oh
okay I don't I don't like that I don't
like what happened there but that is the
thing all righty then
okay yeah also I want to say I really do
like the choice of going with nightmare
mode because it does present joy lady I
don't know really funny to me
coz the first second I was like oh lady
first instinct acts and it's like that's
horrible that's a horrible first
instinct but just gleefully like statue
BAM and then oh man little horrible
horrible horrible anyway what was I
doing
BAM where am I going I need to find the
front door oh it was over in the I don't
have time for no to this yeah alright
alright so there we are a little later
there we go I got to get to a brain goop
specialist soon all right
oh oh ah beautiful damn it son of a
[ __ ] still has Lily yeah and he got
your eye not your eye eye but your your
face your beautiful face Sebastian
square one again damn it
Oh bad Dewey establish contact with the
marker agent Kidman about time patch him
through
Sebastian Sebastian
are you there kind of throne was that
did you guys see that in the back there
this look is small and I was big couch
I'm a businessman I turned on the
emitter and that seemed to slow him down
but he got away and he's gotten Lilly
she must be so scared and alone I've got
to find her before he does something
terrible to her
I'm so close I can feel it
oh look at young Sebastian again look at
young Sebastian Sebastian is old now
that looks like Lily your precious
experiment to fail it would be a real
tragedy to waste all that time and money
I was speaking for myself not Mobius
I spent a lot of time with Lily during
testing she's a good kid I don't want
her to suffer I know things are bad but
I have faith in you you've got to stay
focused so we can save her together
like kind of businessman as a big don't
worry about it but right now you need to
figure out where he took her he said his
name was Stefano Stefano copy that
I'll see what I can find out and send it
to your room okay in the meantime I'll
check in with O'Neill see if he can help
me locate this psycho sounds like a plan
let me know if I can be of any help and
Sebastian yeah
good luck Thanks
can you turn that luck into bullets for
me because that's what I need right now
oh it's almost as if he wants a fight he
wants he's gonna get it man Sebastian's
detective skills here are top-notch you
like you wouldn't believe
sorry that lunatic still has her but I
think I have an idea of where he went
Oh Neil I didn't know you were a
detective nothing would surprise me
you're smashing don't don't ask for
things that you don't want here cuz
that's that's that's not a good way to
live you're gonna you're gonna get in
trouble if you keep doing that yeah it's
no bueno
all right back into the marrow I go I
knew I'd have to go back in the marrow
eventually yeh so I can go back and get
that thing that I forgot that I didn't
get
whatever that was or whatever that may
be here I go oh no I don't want to go
because that's bad that's passed up
moaning lady not camera moaning lady
there's a lot of moaning ladies in here
moaning everyth everything seems to be
moaning in this place and I don't know
if that's a good thing this is bad I
haven't been able to give anyone their
soup yet it's a tragedy
ooh wait a minute what's that oh yeah Oh
coffee
Oh give me that sweet nectar of the gods
pour it down my gullet please ah oh
sweet ambrosia
good old coffee soup alright so we gotta
go I miss boxes and items out whatever
it's all good I don't care who needs a
me but that's no matter
all right kitty-kitty what's going on
kitty all right
oh you're all alone in my brain
mm-hmm there's a cute kitty was that
Lily's kitty Lily okay Lily might have a
kitty all right let's go put uh let's go
let's go
no yeah let's go let's go to the
shooting gallery again because that's
fun
and I need some stuff all right which I
do gallery mode I don't think I've done
anything more yeah I can do the hard
gallery mode let's do that one all right
I'm just this is just to get supply oh
this is the first level of the the first
game
oh how handy that ah damn it no uh whoa
oops well sorry nurse right in your
frickin head there hello peekaboo Oh
peekaboo
all right oh hello okay so far so goo
off two nurses who divvy isn't uncle
that that would be a thing barely got
you ah
Oh God is the killer on the loose oh god
it's space invaders all over again
Oh piss I think I still got it anyway
you may very well be the best
I made Oh me me very M well be the best
oh hell yeah thank you now let's try it
on the hardest mode alright and I can
get a locker key out of that if I do it
right I don't like that this mode you
know what I changed my mind I don't like
this mode oh hello peekaboo piccaboo
parrot up
oh no you use how you smarmy bastard hey
goddamnit
oh god damn it oh god damn I thought he
was gonna move back Rubick Rubick you
[ __ ] get out of here oh ah but no I
was a hundred away you deserve a round
of applause for that I'm sure there's
someone out there that will provide Oh
nurse come on I can do it I swear
I swear I didn't get the last one there
was like 10,000 of something available
in the last one yeah
10,000 Greendale I can do it I know I
can oh yeah yeah yeah
she's got to be better peekaboo
peekaboo oh I see what that does that
slows time down
[Applause]
everybody hold on your hat Oh got you
baby
whoa there's two of you Oh got you baby
oh Jesus
is that Rach oh oh oh come on oh there
we go
Oh God no oh yes that was the big one I
needed that to be able to get yeah I did
it I did it I did it give me a round of
applause oh yes sorry my headphones all
right cool
got that 10,000 big ones 10,000 big wom
bows and now to get a hundred thousand
fifty-one boughs of these oh yeah you
know what I'm going for
do that oh yeah give it back
oh yeah oh yes so money points owes oh
yeah that's the good stuff there we go
that's what I am saying things about it
with my mouth there we go
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh come on that wasn't a combo never go
back
Oh brick you frakkers
what am I going for here I have no idea
everything is broken trying to go for
black I think I can just set that up
better there we go okay let's go for
purple come on yeah all right
Rad's next come on it's right there
there we go
ohyeah ohyeah ohyeah let's go for black
there we go
Oh red red red red red dead redemption
what's now that blue would have been
next but Purple's next okay Purple's
next up crapola come on there we go
there we go there we go
No give me more time okay time for just
speed I don't think we're going to be
able to build combos
ah so close I must say uh I I got I got
oh man I can do I can do it better I
know I can I'm so close
ah my hand is cramping up already I just
started this okay I can do I'm just
gonna give it one more try and if I
don't get on this next one then I'm I'm
not I'm Audi okay we're gonna flag then
read next
oh damn it all red was going there we go
[Applause]
oh damn it
[Applause]
all right
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
no I'm screwed myself so hard ah
again with the screwing of self that I
do oh this is the worst one that I could
possibly go for I haven't been going for
any combos anywhere I've just a terrible
human being in general that's that's
really all that well we can surmise out
of this possibility
[Applause]
Oh oh god there's so many penalties why
no God oh jesus oh Jesus golly gosh
golly gosh and darn gee whiz
that was really just a poor show all
around and I still got 90,000 points I
can do this I'm sure there's some if you
could just shove it up your piehole
tatianna I didn't even know that your
name was tatianna I can do this sorry I
know I said I'll just do one more but I
got this
nice nice epic combo we'll just fill the
whole screen with one color cuz that's
how I do
oh yeah oh yeah that's the stew oh look
at that stew
oh yeah that's how you do that's how you
do that's how you do that's how you do
okay combine all that yeah oh that's how
you do okay then I go for black next
come on combine it all combine it all
find the points come on there we go all
right red
no not again not again with the [ __ ]
Oh God there we go my brain is not able
to work this fast
damnit damnit everytime every goddamn
time see what the hell happened 65,000 I
think it's cuz I kept going for big one
more time I swear one more and then
we're gonna I'm addicted is how gambling
get started
[Applause]
[Applause]
god I don't know what's going on with me
okay no no it's okay I'm out I'm out you
guys gotta keep it secret that didn't
happen that didn't happen that didn't
happen I got middle of the class okay
yeah that's cuz I was I was just
shooting frantically and not
intelligently that was my bad that was
my bad okay anyway I'll get that later
I'll come back to it okay you got it
I've gotta upgrade my pistols firing
rate you just saw me in there unless
that was your twin sister in which case
I don't even want to know I don't even
want to know I got three keys let's go
for bottom left nope don't need that go
for this one bullets i likey that one
that's a good number of parts okay let's
see if I can inject anything in my brain
hello
there's nothing wrong with being
cautious shut up but you can't avoid
fighting forever
wash your face okay what if I um
if I get this will I be so quiet that no
one will ever ever hear me that's what
I'm hoping
I want the grabby hands is because I
want it but I'm gonna spend red gel on
this one and just get this one because
now no one can hear me no one will ever
hear me ever and I'm gonna get grabby
hands yes
bottles will be expended to break free
from certain enemy grab attacks bottles
will be used directly from inventory
they do not need to be equipped you
can't beat these hands these hands are
gonna grab you and a bottle too also
that's also gonna happen whoa whoa all
right so we got that stamina gauge
stamens recovery speed increase that's
what I want yes therefore I can I can
sneak around people and then I can run
away as fast as I can and now you fully
understand what you're up against do is
whatever freak that wondered he is as
driven as you are and seeking the same
thing you are more alike than you care
to admit no I like him he's a murderer
and there are no bodies strewn in the
path behind you I'm not here to debate
with you let's get going
we're not we're not we're not the same
at all no way what are you talking about
there's no way that we're the same stop
that you crazy lady it's insanity to
think that we're the same five-foot-ten
black considers themselves an artist
there's no way that's an impossibility
all right anyway let's carry on yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna do the whole rest of the
playthrough just like this super emo
mode ham I get that right there we go
now we see now we see okay so uh what am
I going for sniper rifle firepower I
don't know if I need that animal
capacity would be good reload time also
handy dandy Oh walk speed while aiming
that's a handy dandy duty oh hell yeah
and that's that's just way better all
right 90 left fire rate yeah why not
make my pistol my best gun which I
always like that's how I play dead space
I played I played it all basically with
the first gun and that was my favorite
thing just because it allowed me to do
whatever I want to do next I'm gonna
check to see if I got any uh got any
more slides I don't know if I did but
we're gonna find out yeah did we I can't
remember if we did not harvested sure no
we didn't get anything else there might
have been another slide in that whole
mansion let me check but there was just
there was just no map data so it was
really hard to find out yeah whatever I
don't think I'm gonna go be able to do a
completionist run of this unfortunately
but the best I can do
yeah because let's see yeah there was
just a workbench in a save point and
that was it like there's no radio
signals in here there's
no nothing there's just a little bit
over here that I didn't explore but yeah
I'm gonna move on even if I miss stuff
unfortunately that's just the way it
goes sometimes I'm never able to do
absolutely completely one I like out
just as soon as you pull your hair in
front of your eyes is silly you're emo
like there's no qualification to it it's
just like emo not emo emo not emo but
I'm gonna stick with this I'm gonna
we're not that alike what are you
talking about I don't even understand
you need to find them all I can't I
can't find them all I can't they can't
do it I'm already going back into the
sewers gotta go sneak mode for this one
there better be someone that I can give
soup to they see how the walking speed
is oh the passage I was talking about
okay then ooh
oh look House me oh look how fast I am
oh so fast I'm so speedy all right then
where does this lead to uh well I don't
like it but it is what it is so here we
go really this is messing with my mind
yeah no joke all right
Oh missed it there we go unlock thank
you caboose key was that unlock the
whole time and I just needed to kick it
really hard I should just try to kick
doors really hard I think that's just a
life policy that we all need to embrace
it's a lot more a lot more kicking of
doors and such and if I need some soup
hey detective Castellanos on the job for
soup hey yeah but you need some soup do
you have some soup all right hello Pat
badass a bit oh oh grandpa told me about
this one oh my sac is grown I'll never
fill up my sac but someday somehow Oh
someone will be proud of me not me right
now but did someone hmm
gunpowder okay good soup I'm out here
I'll never find me what was that over
there Oh weird huh no no no wow hey whoa
hey whoa watch out soups not ready yet
and everybody hold on to your hats I'm
gonna try to do this without wasting the
bullet okay
I'll get it I'll get it I'll get it Oh
stamina sout boom enough salmon to kick
a door down oh oh wait wait
oh no oh ha ha you'll never find me
all right
where'd you go Oh
peekaboo big boo okay I would kick that
door open but it defeat the purposes of
soup delivery got you baby
Oh mmm sweet this is pretty cool hmm I
love that skill so much I love it so
much
also how quiet are my footsteps I might
be able to just like walk around people
instead of having to always go sneak
mode I mean I'm still gonna obviously go
sneak mode but you know I don't have to
all the time now yeah yeah so we gotta
get through here but we're hearing
voices of such people as like Lily which
is a problem state mode engaged
every buck shush shush there's a lot of
moaning happening oh did the lights go
out why the lights go out
oh hey what's that I smell all right
well you guys make up your mind okay
you could witty you just got a flail
there and the coordinated dance that
you're doing
yeah I'm really impressed with your boy
band but I don't want to deal with it
right now okay there we go oh oh oh I
could have hit around that corner in
ambush time I guess
[Music]
are you going okay if you turn around
for even a second I'm coming after yep
you turned around for even a second I'm
coming after you
you didn't hear nothing oh I said you
didn't hear nothing oh nothing
then there's nothing you stupid idiot
you stupid fool you stupid fool you know
what I'm gonna do if he comes back
around here I'm gonna do the
ambush-style
oh never mind he's being stupid
all right fine then I'll bring it to you
right where your friend got suped all
right there we go all right yeah okay
that's enough soup for one day oh I
could have shot that that would have
been easy uh I love my sneaking skills
they make life so much easier than it
once was
all right carrying down Italy do it
it'll air later boy do I seem like the
guy that's not gonna be able to survive
this endeavor I have the skills even if
it's nightmare mode I don't even care I
got the skills for the most incredibly
deadly Close Encounters that you
wouldn't even believe Oh
uh-oh
there was a ghost that's ghost in here
the hell is this stuff uh actual plasm
it's ectoplasmic goo from the ghost uh
Oh gross Oh God yeah yes oh ah I hate
this ah I ain't gonna say it I ain't
gonna say it I ain't gonna say it I'm
gonna say what this always ain't gonna
say it and you guys ain't gonna say it
either no one needs to say it out loud
we're all thinking it
we're all thinking the same thing we're
all thinking the same thing we don't
need to say it doesn't need to be said
out loud
husky Oh nope go to ignore it ah some
good TV to distract me from everything
this looks exactly like that trailer
from South Park where the ectoplasmic
goo and the ghost happened to be a
secret society abducted billion staged
your death
do you realize how crazy that sounds but
it's true why can't you understand that
I know it's hard to accept Luther but
she's gone our little girl is gone but I
have
my right you're obsessed you need rest
once you get past this you'll learn to
accept no if you won't help me I'll find
out the truth on my own you were right
all along
ah a relic from a pre phone camera era
okay well there's oh but why am I seeing
this now was that the fourth slide that
maybe I didn't miss one I don't know
I've got a feeling like I'm not even
halfway through this game because we're
only on chapter six and if I know
anything about these games they usually
go up to either 12 or 13 so I love it
though this is a nice long game it is
one you can take your time with if
you're doing like more of the collective
stuff like I've been doing well I think
I found the source of all this uh
Elmer's glue someone someone had too
much fun
here in this hallway Oh Oh God it moves
oh don't want to look at that do you
move No
Oh yep yeah though okay why did I
suspect anything otherwise Oh
I hate this oh god no
Oh
maybe I could sneak past it I'm gonna
throw up oh my god I'm gonna throw up oh
that's horrible it's horrible it's
horrible why did I go in here Oh wasn't
there another way I was blocked off but
there was something down there can I go
back oh I want to go back I want to go
back hang on okay
there's a way I can go back but I have
to die and I got a feeling that the
death by this thing ain't gonna be
pretty
oh boy oh boy alright well here we go
hey buddy disgusting horrible thing oh
my god that's terrible
why am I so tough now why am I the
toughest thing in the entire world
oh I thought there was gonna be like a
custom animation for death but oh man oh
man that was the worst it closed the
door for a reason it did it closed the
door for a reason oh there's a side room
right here oh that room ah the one
that's all covered in spoiled milk we
got to do this again so all of that was
a waste I didn't need to do that there's
a waste to waste of my time okay let's
just I know I know we're gonna get
through this together guys
I promise oh god the art team that had
to make this level and these monsters Oh
blossom clam chowder that's what it is
yeah it's clam chowder yeah maybe I'm
very stealthy I am exhaust l the-- oh
don't stand up that doesn't help anybody
I'm so sneaky
now-now-now you ain't gonna you ain't
gonna find nothing
I'm the stealthiest human being in the
in the entire world oh oh thank you
thank you for that was that for me oh
why am i out in the open here
no it didn't oh god I got stuck in the
glue oh I'm stuck in the glue oh I'm in
the glue I'm in the glue I I gotta I
gotta oh geez
why didn't you go all the way over
Sebastian why didn't you you have the
option you just chose not to that one
time no one is happy about that no one
is happy none of us are happy I'm not
happy you're not happy none of us are
happy about that what just what just
transpired and I know it's not over
huh boesky not again oh it's out that
scene from dead space
why horrible horrible horrible it's it
is dead space oh good thing I've been
training in the shooting gallery
I got your number oh yeah that's right
Oh Oh God okay well I win I guess uh
awful awful awful awful awful awful
awful awful awful awful awful awful
awful I don't want to know whose
subconscious that was pulled out of can
you imagine the person who whose brain
is orchestrating that monstrosity what's
what what oh hi hello it mmm oh well
never mind then that was a waste of a
bullet all right I'll just wave hello
hello is is this what you wanted to see
is this what you wanted
Sebastian to get a little freaky is this
what you wanted to see cameraman lady
whoever it is is this your subconscious
that dreamt up the Elmer's glue
ectoplasm monster alright well see you
around the bend see ya see ya friend oh
look another door
[Music]
speedy Oh God horrible that's gonna be
in my name err literally forever for I'm
never gonna be able to forget that I'm
gonna be on my deathbed
and you know I'm gonna try to remember
like the faces of my children and I'm
gonna try to remember all the good times
when I was young and then that the giant
jizz monster is gonna appear out of my
brain and I'll be like no and then I'm
dead and then that's gonna be my last
thought before it is imperative that a
missing core be replaced as soon as
possible a core that has been missing
for even a few hours can affect stem
programming if the core is missing for
over 36 hours emergency protocols must
be instituted in order to prevent the
core from escaping emergency protocols
are only accessible for mobius
operatives with alpha security clearance
and it can only be viewed all the marrow
servers okay good great
all right whoo look a lot of supplies in
here good great okay well one one you
give me one [ __ ] I can give me more
than that come on I've got so many herbs
I do not need this many herbs I really
legitimately don't mean need this many
herbs
I mean I'll need this many herbs to try
to forget what I just saw but I I don't
need it okay did I miss anything that
clicked on was closed off okay well I
think I made it so we're good hello
oh the security monitor was in here ah
great good good great googly-moogly
someone's been watching
Oh Lily whoever's been here was
gathering data on her yep there she is
weird Hey Oh guy wait does massive your
Mobius right oh shut up don't say a word
you're not one of us
no I'm not Kidman sent me look I'm here
to help okay my name is Sebastian
Castellanos you're lying
Sebastian Castellanos is dead what No
who told you that turn around do it slow
who are you
your Yukiko Hoffman oh okay you know my
name I told you they sent me in here to
find my daughter Lily the core I'm
telling you the truth
I know you do
lack of micro-expressions and deflection
no verbal parroting I've seen enough to
know you're telling the truth
right the team psychologist
I have to use whatever tools I have to
survive
you're the one that I said was gonna be
tricky combat isn't my fun time mmm but
mine seems to be a running theme here
sorry for putting my gun at you so
they're sending independent contractors
now that means things aren't improving
hmm have you found any other team
members yeah I have but the only one I
found alive is O'Neill Liam is alive
good has he made any progress on
stabilisation the big emitters back on
but this place is still falling apart
and I think it's all because of this
psycho that kidnapped Lilly
coffee's running loose in Utopia they
can manipulate this place at will that
means my theory is correct this is more
than a core disconnect we doctors don't
like to use the term psycho in
pejorative terms uh-huh in this case
it's apropos only a clinically diagnosed
psychopath could affect them like this
uh about the personality type using
Lilly to amplify his power this is the
worst possible situation your shrink any
suggestions on how to defeat him
psychopaths are antisocial lack empathy
in exhibit sadistic tendencies but their
main commonality is their pathologic
egocentricity they don't care about
people only themselves can you think of
anything that would be important to him
yeah he thinks he's some sort of artist
it's all he talks about then maybe the
best way to attack him would be through
his art destroying something valuable to
him could knock him off of his guard I
win dude a little statue people but I've
got to get to him first he's really off
up in the theater right rambled on exit
d5 then it's right here just in the next
room convenient that's pair communicator
so that we can stay in touch okay I'll
review my files and see if I can't dig
up any more information about what's
going on I still feel like there's more
to this regardless he's probably gonna
be difficult to fight feel free to help
yourself to anything here you might need
okay Lily thinks I'm dead does Lily
really think I'm dead I was that just a
part of your lie detecting chest sorry
to break it to you but she does I
thought it was a truth too until just
now but over the years I've learned to
take everything Mobius tells me with a
pinch of salt it wasn't difficult to see
you were telling the truth why would
they do that kind of monsters do you
work for I know it's not right but
consider this Lily is probably less
traumatized by thinking you're dead than
by thinking you're alive but she can't
be with you
yeah maybe it was a messed up way of
thinking about things and when I finally
find her don't worry she'll believe the
evidence of her eyes once she sees you
oh the evidence of her eyes okay yes
good if mobis gonna keep Psychopaths out
of stem then how did one end up in here
I don't know every individual in stem
was subjected to a battery of
psychological exams prior to placement
and we've been observing them from here
in secret to keep an eye out for mental
instability yeah well that didn't work
unfortunately
psychopathy and sociopathy are
incredibly difficult to diagnose
correctly mmm psychopaths tend to be
cunning and highly intelligent aware of
their own diagnosis they're able to
disguise themselves among us the fact
that this one was able to fool us he's
obviously a joy and self aware
disturbingly so great so the tests only
filtered out the weakest of psychos I
feel terribly responsible for all of
this
I hope defies those tests well said you
think there's something more to this I
study the beacon incident extensively so
that we could avoid another disaster
like that in that case the person the
question was the core but even then the
environment remained relatively intact
something just doesn't seem right here
yeah I mean the creatures in here
the dissolution of Union the total
breakdown in communication with Mobius
it just seems like a lot for one person
even with the power of the core he
mentioned someone before another person
who wanted the chorus power no it's too
horrible to contemplate what there's
only one thing that could be more
powerful than a psychopath in here a
super psychopath to do some research
before I can commit to the theory
escucho a psychopath a level 2
psychopath a Super Saiyan psychopath is
that it how close am I say warm or cold
Hoffman that's the only measure I
actually know hot cold whatever fine
you have no help coffee give me that I
need coffee to fix what I just saw
Hoffman did you see did you see what was
in the other room back there
Hoffman did you see cuz I don't want to
scare you or nothing but right outside
the door there's something that'll just
scar you for life and I have a funny
feeling ah
why trippy I can't aim in here but you
guys see it it's coming through don't
like it alright I'll take this hope you
don't mind me taking your jar of blood
here Hoffman just need it for stuff and
things need it for a whole lot of thing
and stuff that I'm gonna be doing and
you don't need to know about whoo what's
this all concerned the ideal core
candidate must have been at have an
unfettered ego in order to retain their
own personality while supporting the
interlinked minds of many others given
these parameters there are only two
possible candidates eight types
egomaniacs with psychopathic tendencies
or children we all know what happened
the last time an egomaniac with
psychopathic tendencies was in stem so a
child is our best bet
having access to standardized school
test results we were able to narrow down
our options we feel well that we found
the ideal core candidate in Lily
Castellanos her tests show that she is
not only as a guileless ego but she also
exhibits incredibly advanced empathy for
a child her age we're sending her to dr.
Hoffman for further testing Oh dr.
Hoffman you you did this girl I'm angry
or something I don't know okay fine then
if there's something else over here oh
and the mirror on the wall that's Andy
Danny I
think I have enough goop to warrant that
but I think it's safe to say that's
alright oh wait how do i how do I get
there is it through this door Pookie
hello-o
alright then wait no is this towards
this is towards what I don't want yeah
this is towards what I don't want
nevermind let me back in please please
oh man okay all right sorry off Minh
just got panicked for a little bit there
you stay on your computer and rest and
relax I'll go out here boom
I'm gonna go stir up some soup you like
soup Hoffmann if you like soup pay
attention to this door if you if you'd
like the opposite of suit like clam
chowder the other door go the other door
is what you're looking for
mmm not good oh yeah what is what is
this was this first smoke bomb oh that
is what it was okay yeah yeah okay so
everything's horrible and everything is
awful but we're gonna go out into Union
post plus and we're gonna see what we
can find over there so see ya off man
see ya yeah often have a good day and
stuff and things it'll eat it did he
lead leading okay so we're gonna go back
into the theater but like like she said
who else could be the one mind that
might be destabilizing things but that
wouldn't make sense because I'm pretty
sure that brain got squashed but then
again not sure anything is real in this
place given that I still don't entirely
trust what's going on with Lily because
Lily all of that just seems seems just
off and I'm not saying it's convenient
but it's convenient enough to convince
the right person that they needed to go
to the right place you know what I mean
oh hello okay cool cool cool right right
right alright let's go out here hop boom
oh wait no it's a safe house alright
so what do we have here let's talk about
you seem dead nice thoughts you've got
in your brain that I can somehow hear
how's your nap so you're just napping
there hey wake up wake up it's time to
get up okay all right
wakey wakey eggs and soup e all right
the theater I'm coming for you
and give me for you yeah sure you are
okay whoa uh yeah
oh no that's uh that's not the kind of
mone I'm in it yep that's a bad that's a
bad mone that's the worst kind of mone
okay what kind of map are we dealing
with in this place okay what am I
looking at okay what do we get we've got
on the hunt investigate the theater
we've also got some kind of other
safehouse over here
I mean this area looks pretty big so I'm
willing to bet that there's a lot to
explore over here so let's get to
exploring before I get to the theater
because you never know what's gonna be
out there to help me Oh
was that you big camera in the sky
psychopathic tendencies person Stefano
can you control your pet God at least
put it on a leash leash laws in this
place we voted in the election where
there was a mayor I jump in here
now it's boarded up okay I don't see any
normal zombies which is what I'd want
I'm gonna I'm gonna do an experiment
here okay I'm sorry you know what I
didn't think that corpse was gonna be a
firework either so not really my fault
push push push push push push push push
push
I call this bush the iron bush okay
screw you guys screw you guys I'm going
home I'm going home guys you guys you
guys are jerks you custard jerks the
ambush didn't work out as I thought it
might work out
oddly enough how weird
okay back out now everything is safe
forever no one's gonna get me a boom
everybody oh oh you didn't hear nothing
okay let's see if I can get this guy at
least
where'd you go you in the bush why are
you hiding in the bush oh gosh dang it
well you're gone so let me see if I go
find firework corpse over there and get
the goop out of them at least that'll be
something nice a year a year okay
oh there you are okay oh I see you okay
let's see what's going on here you all
just woke up after all that out no no
stop not there not there not there not
there okay so I just got to get you to
turn around I can sprint and stab you
ooh this one's angry there we go okay
we're not clear clear but you know let
me just grab this and go oh maybe I'm
getting in here I get in here with a
lock on this door oh I don't know what
where'd this goop come from I'll take it
random floor gloop okay sure fine
whatever oh oh they're fast
oh oh they're done I guess I guess
they're just done ahh oh it's too far
we'll never get them is so fast Wow
oh geez fun I just love like the core
gameplay of this game is just fun
because it's it's like scary right but
also it's incredibly silly when you get
into the meat of the matter like it's
funny ooh
pile of corpses out hi Chad every team
what are you doing here okay anything on
this bus that I should know about Chad
what keep all my soup to myself God you
tried to do something nice for people
and they just don't trust you I don't
know it's all about oh that thing is
angry ooh what do we got here oh geez
I'm right here so good smart smart
I know those whoa what how why how and
why Oh
oh I shouldn't honk my horn so honky oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh yeah yeah that's
that's not what I wanted
oh boy well that's bad
oh are you stuck
hello lady you all right over there well
I don't nearly have the resources with
which to be able to beat you so oh I'm
gonna go over here now excuse me
bird may just go lap up a storm back
into your pilot why know that no the
opposite no don't
good that's right before yeah you better
run oh no you heard her talking [ __ ] Oh
God
I was I'm sorry it was an accident the
words you fell out on my mouth
it wasn't actually me it was a my my
twin was a ghost
ectoplasmic ghost all right
okay well that didn't work out huh funny
about that it's amazing that that didn't
work out for me
oh jeez
hello lady go back into your van just
slip back right in there no don't hit
you don't hear me talking [ __ ] we got
over here oh this is so silly
oh well this game hello's games so much
right see what's up here are you okay
nope boink hello
anybody in here sneaking mood anybody
hello was that guys seeing a nightmare
from his childhood or something what the
hell yeah I guess if everything's in
your mind then the deepest parts of your
psyche would come through wouldn't they
huh huh what don't just go huh Sebastian
don't just go home don't just go home
don't just go home and Oh what thing
were you talking about dude
what thing Oh
what where
shut up oh I didn't want you to shut up
like that
why is everything actually listening to
me
yiii horrible horrible horrible things
horrible horrible why did I come in this
diner I just wanted a coffee oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh my god I got
our guy
what do i do what do i do I can't get
out
Oh what do I do
Oh nope don't like that you turn off my
life that'd be smart how about I do that
yeah okay
oh the body's gone that's wonderful what
did I just see
Oh down there okay
I'm super stealthy I don't know where
you went I don't know where you went I
don't know where you went oh oh there oh
I see I see now where you went
cuz you went down the way I was trying
to go excuse be boobity boobity boobity
something tells me a bottles not gonna
convince you of anything in this
endeavor peek-ee-boo
come on down lady lady well away I don't
let you my lady
yeah thank you thank you could you move
on did you move on Lala lady okay go for
it now
[Music]
don't turn around don't turn around you
don't need to turn around here okay go
go go go go go go go welcome hey y'all
okay good
yes excellent that's what I wanted to do
why does it keep looking like back in
the back in the hospital it keeps
looking like back in beacon hospital and
that can't be unintentional right
something about this lady too oh oh oh
that is not what I wanted
[Music]
this time
what does that thing want from me
Oh mirrors don't mean the same thing
here squeak oh god it is like beacon
Hospital
oh no okay
oh so bright and sunny in here beautiful
BAM hello
okay well that's weird this one also BAM
hello okay cool
all right well this is peculiar oh I
don't know don't like I can't control
the camera hello oh it's me
that's me from back then back then okay
oh hi hello I'm gonna go this way are
you stuck
which way you going you're not in here
what oh wait Oh in the reflection one of
these doors wait one of the hallways has
a light ooh that one right there
okay got it this one has a light coming
from it Oh God
there's the goo okay all right moving on
super weird beard okay all right then oh
boy I don't like this they're mirror and
I see which one has okay all right all
right all right all right all right okay
you know what I don't like that and you
don't like me and I don't like you and
I've seemed to have sucked myself in a
corner here
okay wait oh that door that one right
there I think no that's the farthest one
the one closest to [ __ ] know what oh
[ __ ] what okay wait uh yeah the one
closest to the hallway
Lala lady no one likes you Lala lady oh
I I didn't make that noise down ami oh
good okay going down the hallway
doodly-doo going down the hallway
no you're just where are you going
alright I'm gonna go for it you know
what I'm gonna go for it yeah I'm ready
for it okay
Alma head
oh good I'm back here great hey great I
don't know why man you know I don't know
I don't know man I just don't know
anything in this bathroom
little medical kit I don't think I need
you know I'm full up at this med kit in
here I've got so many medical supplies I
don't even know if I'll ever need it uh
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah ok I'm out
here now I got slide who a trash can
I hate this place
junk junk useless junk nothing good for
me okay I got to be close to there's
there's another safe house right there
let me see if I can make my way to that
one oh hi oh okay I'll take a normal
monster please yes thank you for my
light off oh there's a fire fire person
here and a lot of boxes oh there's too
far
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm sorry just seeing three zombies with
fire in their hands running in a
perpetual palette corpses I don't know
why that's making me laugh that seems
perfectly normal
what is this game I love it I love it so
much all right where am i I'm nowhere
near where I'm supposed to be you know
what you guys are so awesome I'm gonna
leave you alive I know there's boxes
here of supplies that I can get but
goddamn
I just don't it wouldn't feel right if I
disturb your fun times you you guys may
be in a perpetual nightmare of a guy you
know how to make it fun God thank you
for that you know thank you you have a
good day no you have a good day you have
a good day all right okay take care take
love take care and love oh boy I think I
got to go buy this thing jeez I don't
remember the last time I saved all right
hey what's whoa is that over no come on
no no no no hey bud how I was very
sneaky maybe it's cuz you're so high up
and you got so many heads you're just
very aware of everything in your
surroundings oh that's why am i why am I
not running why am I not running was in
trouble I don't care if someone's in
trouble
I'm in trouble do you see the trouble I
see the trouble oh yo-oh yo-oh yo-oh yo
yeah okay I don't know where the safe
house is I have no idea I've kind of
really Bob ah I'm sorry that almost got
me
oh whoa okay you know what
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine Chad
Chad Chad every teen oh god I have no
idea where the safe house one is that is
the safe house in there can I go in
there oh this is a risk okay can you
follow me in No haha
loser oh I'm close I'm close Frick Oh
dick Frick this for you okay alright I
gotta go a little more this way maybe I
can just sneak there's no way there's no
way no way all right
oh no no no no Mattie I'm outie this
wasn't it oh but there's barrels that I
can I can I can eventually go that thing
through the environment and be able to
to beat it down but I'm just looking for
the safe house right now oh come on
maybe I can get the jump on them Chad oh
that's not Chad oh okay come on oh you
[ __ ] just shut up man
man okay I'll get this what's this
what's this watch this guy's watch some
pro level soups killing happen one soup
down Oh one to skip to my soup am i
right everybody am I right people am i
hey whoa
well oh well that ain't good that's not
what I wanted that's not ideal soup
scenario babe
ow [ __ ] oh damn it Oh jum just a
terrible shot great with soup not with
this blam baby you got wham bam Dan
thank you oh god damn it you hurt so bad
all right get down what you guys pay
attention dude well good thing I'm a
good shot
yeah you're welcome Jesus wrong with you
man we shouting at me
wasting all my ammo I could have sneaks
knocked all of them no [ __ ] they're
coming from I'm what what what do you
mean they're coming from over there
they're in front of a freakin face oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy I'm dead okay
well you know what [ __ ]
I didn't ask for this I just wanted to
go to a goddamn safe house I could have
souped them all to infinity and a soup I
could have done that and then you had to
come up walking up on me
being like a big old dick nozzle being a
sack of [ __ ] berries that you are oh my
god okay you know what
you know what you know what you know
what you know what I'm gonna blow you a
sock they got set enough oh yeah too
close too close for blowing all right
well you seem to have cornered me enough
and a precarious situation here but ring
around the rosy pocket full of posy yeah
go [ __ ] yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay hang on hang on hang on
Oh miss me douche okay you're not too
bad you're not too bad come here come
here come here come here I swear it's
gonna be cool all right okay okay oh oh
this is the opposite of good why why is
everyone being an [ __ ] all at once no
now I know you're fast but you don't
need to prove it yeah yeah
yeah okay la la la la da da da da da oh
oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez this is
like the worst of every situation uh
this game got a lot harder all this oh
hi okay you know you I don't need you
either I'm just gonna go in here where
it's safe
am i alive somehow hey you give me don't
bite as I scream in your general
direction good yeah distract that one
okay why am I not able to what Wyatt
okay well oh one down whoa okay let me
just hang
there you go - on fire whoa what yo
you're on Oh fire zombie I've created a
terrible situation okay well I'm good I
got this oh god damn it
I just want to get to the safe room
because I actually got to go cuz we're
filming today but my god these guys are
just being a big bunch of [ __ ] okay
you know what
I'm just gonna you know I bet it'd be
easier if I just booked it across town
at this point yeah I call me a big big
scaredy baby [ __ ] feel free to call me
that I don't deserve this kind of abuse
I don't deserve it
excuse me I'm running why did I stop oh
Jesus God Sebastian what's going on with
your legs man your legs are not okay oh
geez oh geez Scoob okay I just got yeah
I got it I got to go save because we got
to get going we got ton of stuff we're
filming like four videos today and we're
gonna film a whole bunch of stuff
tomorrow
hello God just let me live my life
please oh boy how did I get so far away
from home how did I do this push baby
push
oh that's not good everyone's trying to
sneak snuck on the sneaks nan Kerr and
I'm coffee please and it's so much
coffee
I just wanna be safe and happy I just
want to be happy and safe god no stop
don't you dare I'm out of stamina but
that doesn't mean that you should do
anything about it okay no I'm a boink
Sebastian Castellanos is outie outie
5000 I know there's a key I know I know
don't have time no time ah okay anyway
this has been a crazy episode but it's
been fun all that time for now but good
god okay so thank you everybody so much
for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below I will be back again I
won't be able to stream tomorrow morning
but I will be streaming this weekend
probably in the evenings and probably a
whole bunch more not same time tomorrow
unfortunately because we got a big
filming day tomorrow but that just means
more cool content coming for you so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye bye guys Abid bye bye